en la sociedad civil rusa a grandes
rasgos Cuáles serían los distintos
recuerdos que perduran de stalin a día
de hoy Y cómo han variado en el tiempo
desde su muerte hasta la actualidad
digamos que la guerra Ucrania ha
cambiado un poco la perspectiva de
staling en la sociedad rusa podemos
decir que Putin Hasta cierto punto
quiere equiparar el logro de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial El Triunfo de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial a manos de stalin con la
guerra que él Libra en Ucrania contra
occidente por lo tanto podemos decir que
en los 90 la figura de stalink todavía
sigue sigue haciendo muy controversial
pero ya después del 2010 2014 con la
anexión de crimea vemos que la figura de
alguien empieza a tener como mayor
importancia en la definición de la
identidad rusa no está dignación Georgia
es étnicamente georgiano como usted muy
bien dijo lideró la industrialización de
la unión soviética y ganó la guerra de
acuerdo a los historiadores de la unión
soviética en la unión soviética la
guerra se gana gracias a la intervención
de de su estrategia pero
sí causó mucho malestar y mucho dolor en
millones de rusos en millones de de
distintas étnicas por la represión tan
aguda que cometió para controlar
toda la población la policía secreta de
stalin fue muy brutal persiguió a
cualquier disidente y no solamente eso
sino está bien se le considera a la
persona responsable por las hambrunas
que sufrió Ucrania en los treinta no que
se le llama honodomo No y se había
considerado como una hambruna que se
hizo a propósito para castigar un poco
al movimiento ucraniano
que tenía unos intereses nacionalistas
quería promover la identidad ucraniana y
se vio Hasta cierto punto como una forma
de castigar ese pueblo en los treinta y
murieron aproximadamente unos cinco seis
millones de campesinos y personas
ucranianas por lo tanto es una figura
muy controversial particularmente ahora
por un lado por su por su brutalidad
Pero por otro lado porque logró unificar
a la población soviética no solo rusa en
el momento de la de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y por el triunfo que le a esa
sociedad En aquel momento y precisamente
respecto lo que apuntaba al principio de
su respuesta como en el marco de la
guerra en Ucrania Putin digamos en las
esferas más elevadas a del kremlin se
puede estar revisitando esta imagen de
stalin no esto sucedería solamente en
los digamos en los puestos de poder en
la imagen a política en la comunicación
política o también entre la sociedad
encontramos Este cambio en la percepción
del legado de stalin
nueva generación en la percepción
una gente modernizador un agente de
Progreso y una figura que consolidó el
pueblo Ruso y que se enfrentó a
occidente Si vemos bien que hoy Rusia
Aparentemente está aislada no a pesar de
que tiene contacto con China la India y
otros países está muy aislada de Europa
y de occidente y algo así se vivió en la
época de stalin no luego de la
revolución rusa Revolución bolchevique
en los veinte y los treinta pues la
unión soviética estaba básicamente
aislada de los distintas instituciones
internacionales por lo tanto se puede
pueden haber comparativas no entre ese
periodo y el periodo que se está
viviendo ahora así que me parece que a
pesar de que la figura de staling entre
ciertos sectores de la población siempre
se vio con cierto respeto creo que luego
de la Guerra de Ucrania y luego de los
enfrentamientos a Ucrania en el 2014
pues Putin ha querido utilizar la imagen
de héroe de stalin y compararse con él
por lo tanto creo que ahora mismo en la
generación joven la interpretación de lo
que fue él para la sociedad rusa está
cambiando contrario a otras generaciones
en los 90 o en el sesenta en los setenta
en donde a pesar de que se consideraba
estar en una figura importante no se
podía olvidar el dolor no porque
vemos a los familiares no los
descendientes de aquellos que que
sufrieron la represión y Aunque eso se
recuerda pues ya se está olvidando un
poco en los libros de historia que se
están publicando allá en ruso se se
enfatiza más bien su rol como héroe y
como consolidar consolidar no eh la
sociedad y usted dice que Putin no se ha
querido comparar con él en cierta manera
y desde occidente también se han emitido
muchas comparaciones entre Putin y
stalin a raíz de la invasión de Ucrania
pero usted cree que hay planos hay
puntos realmente donde hacer esta
comparación entre los dos líderes
bueno Putin es un líder muy fuerte ha
querido unificar la sociedad detrás de
unos valores él considera son los
valores que representan a la sociedad y
la la iglesia ortodoxa rusa en contra a
lo que el proyecta como
el desvío moral de de occidente por lo
tanto hay una ideología detrás de eso
pero me parece que Putin no tiene la
capacidad ni el control que tuvo stalin
en su momento de la sociedad no está
Alguien fue atrás de todos sus
disidentes pero la población rusa luego
de los noventa y los dos mil es una
población muy diversa muy crítica que
tiene distintas opiniones y las hace
sentir y a pesar de que hay una gran
propaganda para para vender verdad este
discurso que viene de de Moscú Yo creo
que es una población más compleja y más
difícil de controlar contrario a los a
los años cuarenta donde está el sí tenía
el control